hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar gather
receptive microglia selectively sculpt
developing
inhibitory circuits i'm alexis cross of
leopards
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by vizgen to learn more
about our sponsor
please visit their website at vizgen.com
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers for
today dr loyd benon
clarman cell observatory broad institute
of harvard and mit
and dr amelia favuzzi harvard medical
school and broad institute of harvard
and mit
i will now turn it over to george
emanuel visgen co-founder and director
director of technology and partnerships
to begin our presentation
welcome sir
thanks for the introduction and i'm
excited to be here today to set the
stage for our speakers
so this is fizdin's first talk in our
series that provides a forum for some of
our early adopters for bridgeton's
smurfish platform to present the
research they've been
using this platform to enable but as the
scientists focused on developing new
technologies it's really most exciting
to me to see that
these technologies that we're developing
are actually
working to to lead to real world
scientific
discoveries that we'll hear about a
little bit later today
but before we get too much into the
science i just want to give a brief
introduction
of this gin so just uh briefly i'll i'll
describe both what murphy's technology
is
to set the stage for what you'll hear a
little bit later and also i'll describe
what bison is doing to help
make murfish technology more accessible
through our
scope solution so at the broadest sense
we consider the next wave of spatial
genomics technologies
as really the next iteration of not just
spatial technologies but
genomics technologies with bulk
sequencing
you're able to count the number of rna
transcripts within
a large tissue block to understand which
genes might be upregulated or down
regulated in different
situations or different drug treatments
and really understand
more about which what each of these
genes is doing
but there you lose two fundamental
components of the biological system
you lose the single cell information
because each individual cell
is responding to its micro environment
expressing a different subset
of the gene so understanding what each
cell
is expressing it's really critical to
understand the biology
the second is the spatial information
because these cells aren't just working
in isolated droplets
they're very intricately communicating
with each other
and the surrounding environment and
responding in order to
really uh best sort of construct this
full biological system
so more recently in the last five to
eight years we've seen the widespread
adoption of single cell sequencing
technologies which get you the single
cell information but then you still lose
the spatial component
but now with facial genomics with
murphish
technology you're able to perform this
highly multiplex measurement
to measure the number of transcripts
that get you a good
idea of what each cell is doing while
maintaining the single cell
context because of the very high spatial
resolution
and at the same time maintaining the
spatial component
so that's what bisgen is really excited
about bringing to the market
before i go into what the merscope
platform actually looks like
i'll i'll first introduce the murfish
technology this highly multiplexed
high-resolution spatial genomics
technology
so murfish is a technology that builds
upon single molecule fish
in single molecule fish you design
fluorescently labeled probes that
specifically bind to a target transcript
so that when you look at this under a
high resolution fluorescence microscope
each of the targeted rna transcripts
shows up as a diffraction limited spot
in the microscope so then by counting
the number of spots
you can directly quantify the expression
of this gene across the biological
sample so
combined with cell segmentation for
example you can see how this gene
expression varies
across different cells so as with
traditional fluorescence technologies
single molecule fish is just limited to
being able to measure
a few genes at once maybe three or
sometimes five if you're using
all the available colors but there's
tens of thousands of relevant
transcripts within each
biological system so murfish is a
technology that builds upon single
single molecule fish to greatly increase
the multiplexing capacity
so just as a brief introduction we'll
hear more
about more fish and how it's used later
on but murfish
is able to overcome this multiplexing
gene throughput challenge by instead of
reading genes out one at a time
we assign each of them a binary barcode
and then we read out that binary barcode
using sequential rounds of single
molecule fish
so as you see here after we stain the
sample
we're able to stain the sample in such a
way that first
we're able to read out the first bit and
the binary barcode as shown on the left
hand side of this image here
all of the genes that were assigned a
barcode that contained the one
for the first position show up as the
single molecule fish spot
while all the genes that were assigned a
barcode that contained the zero and the
first position remain dark
so this reads out the first position and
the barcode
then we can extinguish the signal we
same for the next round the next round
and next round
and then by the pattern of brightness
and darkness across this
image stack we're able to identify the
gene at each
facial position across the sample so
this enables the very highly multiplexed
spatial transcriptomics measurement but
from the way that technology works
there's just a couple advantages
that i want to highlight briefly first
it's the image-based technology so in
order to capture more cells we just move
the x-y stage across larger tissue areas
so in a typical morse scope measurement
we can measure up to a square centimeter
of tissue
and capture hundreds of thousands of
cells within vinson we've demonstrated
murfish on a broad variety of different
mouse and human tissues
murfish builds upon single module fish
which in many cases
is considered a gold standard for
quantifying rna abundance and we
maintain that very high sensitivity as
we increase this multiplexing capacity
next murfish is a single molecule
measurement so we have single
molecule resolution across the whole
tissue area that we image
so with this a single molecule
resolution we can really perform
not just single cell level analysis but
also analysis on the intracellular
organization of the transcriptome
and finally with this binary encoding
scheme we have custom
multiplexing capacity where we can very
easily
tune the length of the barcode to target
hundreds or
thousands of different genes or as we
hear about later it's even
efficient to to use murfish to very
accurately quantify
even smaller panels of genes on the
order of tens of genes
because the smurfish encoding scheme
provides a lot of error robustness
to to really guarantee that you're
getting the right results out of the
murfish measurement
but as with any genomics technology it
should be both
very highly quantitative and highly
reproducible so here for this mouse
brain slice
with the murfish measurement we we
measured the full coronal slice and we
can zoom into any region across this
brain slice
and really see exactly where each
transcript is being expressed
so when we compare this to bulk
sequencing we find very good correlation
between murfrees and bulk sequencing
and also when we compare replicate to
replicate we also find
very good correlation even in terms of
absolute copy number
uh between replicant measurement
okay so to better explain what i mean by
the high detection efficiency or high
efficiency
of a murfish measurement we can best do
that in comparison with what's available
on the spatial genomics market so here
we did a matched measurement
between mursco and this oligo ray bass
platform
so when we compare the copy number
detected with mursco
and the copy number detected in this
match sample with the algorithms
platform
we we find that murfish routinely
detects 70 fold more transcripts
so since transcriptomics is already a
relatively sparse signal especially at
the single cell level
for many transcripts you only detect
maybe 10
of some of these functionally relevant
genes and a lot of cells
so for example if we look at this opioid
receptor
delta one gene when we plot out the
expression with murfish we see this very
rich spatial organization
well if we look at the expression with
the oligoarray-based platform we just
see a few spots across the oligo
grid where there's just maybe one or two
copies of this transcript that were
detected
so because of these advantages we're
really excited to
start to enable more researchers to run
murfish measurements to
advance their own research so murphish
itself was
originally published in 2015.
since then there's been a number of
publications both from xiaowei's dwang's
lab
at harvard but also a number of other
research labs that have applied
murphish to a number of different
biological questions
and there's also a growing number of
institutions that are already using
merfish
so you can see here this doesn't even
include some of the ones that this gen
is enabling
such as the road that you'll hear about
in the talk today so that's murfish
technology but then
we also want to make warfish technology
much more accessible
and we're doing that through merscope
which is this platform solution
for integrated spatial genomics so
merscope
is this instrument that performs the
foamer fish measurement so within the
box
on the left there's a microscope and a
fluidic system to
perform this iterative imaging
extinguishing and restaining in order to
automate the foamer fish process
so merscope really combines the
advantages of murfish chemistry
with an automated easy to use instrument
and a whole
reagent and software ecosystem
so with that i'd like to turn it over to
our two speakers for the
for the day amelia fubuzi and lauric
binon
who have been working with us as early
adopters of the mursco platform
hope you're excited as i am to hear
about the research that they've been
doing
with our early marscope instrument
hello everyone thank you for that
introduction
um so i'm amelia farouzi and uh um i'm
really thankful for the opportunity to
share our work today and uh um let's
jump right into it
so we know that brain circuits are
extremely complex but also
very specific so the overarching
question we're interested in is how does
this
arise during development for example
imagine you ask these two
people to learn a new language who will
learn it faster
and uh better well likely the kid at the
top
and uh why because her brain is at
this stage here where neurons are
forming
synapses at very high speed and then
this is followed by a period of synapse
pruning where the brain gets rid of all
the
extra connections and as a result of
that the remaining
wiring is more refined and more
efficient
and that's why when a connection is used
repeatedly during development it then
becomes
uh permanent and so synapse pruning is
needed for
precise brain wiring but what does
regulate pruning
uh well several processes but in the
last years work from
many labs has shown that uh microglia
play critical goal in this process
and microglia are the brain immune cells
and they have this really ramified
morphology and with their processes they
continuously
survey their environment and until
relatively recently it was thought
microglia would just
be there become activated in response to
tissue damage or
infection and essentially clean up
toxins or
that neurons that's of course still true
but
now we know that microbials who play a
number of non-inflammatory functions
during normal
uh brain development including the
regulation of
synapse pruning but when we think about
synapses they're not really like this
they are more
like this very heterogeneous and that's
true at both
the molecular and the functional
level and the best example of this is
the dichotomy between excitatory
and um inhibitory synapses and so
when we think about the role of
microglia in synapse pruning we really
don't know whether they are
genetic effectors of synapse pruning or
if they can discriminate between
distinct types of
synapses and so in this work we explore
the hypothesis that
functional microbial diversity has
evolved to ensure pruning of inhibitory
versus
excitatory uh synapses and we can really
break this down in three specific uh
questions first do microglia regulate
the development of the
inhibitory circuits and if that's the
case then what are the
underlying cellular and molecular
mechanisms and third what happens then
at the behavioral level if we
uh disrupt the the interaction and so
like i said at the beginning we didn't
even know whether microbial would
actually regulate the development of the
inhibitory circuits and so we started
using a relatively uh blunt tool
we depleted microglia for the first
supernatal wiximizer using a
pharmacological strategy
and as you can see here this is very
efficient there's virtually no microglia
left
in the cerebral cortex and that's true
from p4
throughout development until pcc when we
then stop our depletion
protocol and ask what happened to the uh
cortical circuits and we focus on um two
types of inhibitory synapses those made
by some extracting positive
interneurons that target the dendrites
of excitatory neurons
and parvalbumin positive synapses that
exert a strong perisomatic
inhibition to their focus more on pv
synapses
and then for comparison we also looked
at um excitatory
synapse then we did that in the mouse uh
somatosensory cortex
so like i said we started looking at uh
pv
synapses and we found that they were
increased in
microglia depleted mice and this
increase could only be detected
after the initial assembly of these
synapses so after p12
suggesting a role for microglia in the
maturation or refinement of these acids
rather than really in their uh formation
then we asked whether the structural
increase in synapses was paralleled by a
functional increase in pv inhibition
and so for that we used optogenetics we
expressed
channel rhodopsin in pv cells stimulated
them and recorded from
uh excitatory neurons and we found a
higher response in
microgreat depleted mass so
in my introduction i mentioned how
extraordinary brain development is you
know circles
are plastics and learning is really
facilitated but
brain development is also an
exceptionally sensitive time window when
even
sub colon cells can cause alterations
that will last throughout life
so that's why we asked so what happens
if you let microglia repopulate
uh the brain after p15 will
the synapses catch up and here you can
see that at p30
the depleted brains are essentially
indistinguishable from
the control so microglia do repopulate
uh the brain
but when we looked at the synapses the
hyperconnectivity
the fat was still there suggesting that
depleting
microglia during development causes
long-lasting defects
in inhibitory synapses
then we also look at excitatory synapses
for comparison
um and here we're focusing on thalamic
inputs and consistent with previous work
we found that there were also
increase in the
depleted mice both structurally and
functionally using
physiology so if we go back to
our first question we uh we can now say
that when you
if you deplete microglia during
development you'll have an increase in
both
excitatory and inhibitory synapses
suggesting that indeed might be are
important
for the development of the inhibitory
circuits but then
now we can ask is this really due to a
direct interaction
of microglia with these uh synapses and
so
for that we labeled pv synapses
in red using adenine associated viruses
that express
synaptophytes into the tomato under the
control of a pv specific
enhancer and we injected these virus in
mice with a genetically labeled
microglia
and what you can see here is that the
processes of microglia really wrapped
around these
synapses like in these examples um a
subset of these synapses was also
encapsulated within microglia and
colloquialized with
microglial lysosomes suggestive of
engulfment
but perhaps even more interestingly we
found that these contacts were
developmentally regulated so there was
an increase between
p2l and p15 and the highest number at
p15 p17 and then they decrease the gain
at p30 but of course this is just a
screenshot
now we can ask how do these contacts
last or
how long and how what happens when uh
synapse is conducted and so
to answer these questions we um use the
same leveling tools that i just
described
and did uh in vivo to photon imaging of
microglia pv synapse interactions uh in
layer four
of the small sensor cortex and we did
that at the peak
contact uh period p1517
and what you can see here is a microglia
that over a period of 13 minutes really
contacts the the majority of the
pv synapses around so first on the left
and at the bottom
and so on uh top and when we do this
for several cells and several animals we
can really get an idea of
what happens uh on average and the first
thing that we noticed was
a bimodal behavior of microglia
so there was a first group of cells that
almost avoided previous and after
contact very few of them
and then a second group of cells that
contacted the majority of
pv synapses around up to 60 70 of them
and we also found that um within the
populations that
the population that conducted less pv
synapses the interactions that did occur
had a significantly shorter duration as
compared to
the interactions within uh the
population that was
more actively engaged with uh pv
synapses
so then we asked so what signal
different uh interactions and so for
that we
uh mined published transcriptional data
to identify
ligand receptor pairs that were
selectively expressed in inhibitory
neurons magnetic size 3 neurons and
microglia
during development and the more the the
the top candidates the with this gappa
gaba b receptor uh
pair and actually this is a strong uh
precedent uh
in addition to its role as a
neurotransmitter gaba acts as a
periclean signal
to regulate several developmental
processes like progeny for proliferation
neuronal
migration synapse formation and most of
these functions are actually mediated
through gaba-b
receptors on the other side the uh
previous work in the adults had shown
that a subset of microglia
expressed uh gabba b receptors and
they actually respond to gaba for
instance by changing their uh motility
and so the first thing that we did was
to confirm that fp15 in the summer
sensory cortex uh
around 20 to 30 percent of microglia
expressed
both gaba b receptor uh subunits
and we also found that the pv synapses
were preferentially contacted by these
gaba effective
uh microbial whereas the opposite was
true for
excitatory synapses they were
preferentially contrasted by
microglia that did not express gabap
receptors
so then we uh removed gaba b recessors
from microglia using two distinct crease
driver lines
and uh what we found was that the
knockout uh
microglia contacts significantly fewer
pv
uh synapses but when we uh looked at the
excitatory once we found that the
proportion of excitatory senses
conducted by
uh gala binocular microglia uh was
unchanged
so then we went back to our individual
to photon imaging
experiments and repeated these
experiments in the knockout and
this is the control that i show you with
the bimodal distribution that i showed
you earlier
and when we repeated it in the knockout
we found that the
these interactions were no longer
bi-modal and actually
more closely resemble those that
interact less
uh with pb synapses so we thought well
it really looks like this
um gaba recessive microbial might be
dedicated to
remodel uh inhibitory synapses but
then if that's the case then these
knockout mice should have connectivity
defects they're
somehow similar to what we found when we
completely uh depleted uh microglia
right
and what we found was quite remarkable
so again we looked at pv synapses
in gaba binocular mice and we found that
they were increased
in the knockout both structurally and
functionally
using physiology so what this means is
that removing
baby receptors from microglia
phenocopies that effect
on inhibitory synapses that we had seen
when we had completely
depleted microglia but then we looked at
excitatory
synapses and here we found no effect and
so
what this means is that removing obama
receptors from microbial also
decouples that is fat and inhibitory
versus excitatory synapses that we have
seen in the uh
the microglial depleted mice and so then
we went
on and looked for the molecular
mechanisms
downstream of gaba-b receptors in
microbial
and for that we isolated microglia from
the somatosensory cortex
of pisitine control and gababino count
mice
and we did a single cell rna sequencing
and the first thing that we did was to
integrate control and
uh knock out mice and knockout cells and
you can see here that they align pretty
well
this also segregates in eight mixed
clusters and of course i want to have
time to describe these clusters in the
details but an important message here is
that
uh removing gaba-b receptors from
microglia doesn't fundamentally alter
the range of microglial states that can
be
observed in the nocal and so then within
each of these clusters we compared
control and knockout cells uh and and
we found that the cluster where they
were more different was this cluster 4
here
now cluster 4 contains microglia
expressing higher levels
of what is known as homeostatic
microbial core genes
uh and higher levels of pruning genes so
they're more mature microglia that are
more likely to
carry out pruning functions and so then
we looked at the identity of these
differentially expressed
uh genes and we found that they were
broadly involved in pruning and when i
say broadly involved improvement what i
mean is that
they really involve classical pruning
genes but also genes involved in
motility migration cell cell adhesion
and phagocytosis and so
it's really not one or two genes that
are altered it's a whole program that is
uh that is different in this in these
knockout cells
but then when we looked at the down
regulated genes with a single cell
resolution we found that they were
altered
only in a in a subset of this
microgravity cost
for around 25 of them and these same
cells
segregate as a transcriptionally
distinct cluster within
class 4. so the question now is are
these
cells gather effective microglia and
unfortunately we really couldn't answer
this question
with um single-cell or single-cell data
because
gaba b receptors are expressed at low
levels
in microglia and this is and so we could
really couldn't
um we had an incomplete detection of
gaba receptive microglia and this is
known as
dropout events so that's why we started
a wonderful collaboration with
like uh it's gonna speak now and uh
semi-fire the broad institute where we
did
more fish profiling of control and
knockout microglia again fp15 in the
summer sensory cortex
to answer uh this question now like it's
going to give you a broader overview
and then we'll come back showing you
what we found about that
thank you so once you've decided
that you want to use murphy for your
experiment
um what are the steps you need to take
first you need to
put together a list of genes that you
are going to measure in your sample
which i'm showing you here and then uh
because
that list has a lot of genes we don't
want to
image each of these genes separately and
um we're going to multiplex the
experiment that means
that we associate to that list against a
code book
such as the one that i'm showing here
which tells you
that any transcript for gabber one is
going to be performed
in the image one two six and ten of the
sample
so what that actually means uh when you
do the data acquisition
uh on the scope we have five color
channels
one is used for uh imaging the nuclei
adapti
one is used in green to image uh
fiducial bits that we use to realign the
images during rounds
so that leaves us with three useful
channels for
the data and so if we look back at that
codebook we can see
that in imaging round one the images one
and two will show
spots forever one and those but will
also be fluorescent
in the third image of immigrant two not
at all in image round three
and again uh in the image of me
and some more things for all of those
genes in that list
so um on top of that we also added a
couple of genes that we measured
with an sm fish design so just one color
one channel at a time for those teams
the reason we
did that is that those genes are either
expressed as very low levels such as
gebor2 and we wanted to really make sure
that
we would be able to pick them up or some
of those were
very short and we weren't able to fit
enough probes
on them to do more fish i'm going to
explain that in article later
so once you've decided that you want any
transcripts for
ever want to be percent in these images
uh what's the next step uh this gently
will design and sell custom libraries of
probes that are
going to do that the way that works is
that we have a
library of encoding probes that have
this u-shaped
such as are shown here that are going to
tile
the rma of the transcript we want to see
usually we have at least 20 of these
encoding probes per rna which allows
for our signal lumination
um okay at this point we still have
nothing that is very recent
and the next step is during the
acquisition we are going to be
flowing in the radar probes which
are actually the fluorescent uh probes
and these will anneal on those arms that
are on each side of the
encoding probe so we will first pull
three of these to
require the three colors of image round
one then
flow in a two-page buffer that's going
to remove just the plural form here
so that we can then flow in the next
three fluorescent probes
and repeat until we've acquired the
whole code
so doing this uh generates
images such as this one where you can
see
that we have a lot of isolated spots
each of these corresponds to one of the
transcripts that are supposed to be
fluorescent
in round one which is the first column
on the left
so it can be either of those genes and
the way to know which one they are is to
also look
at the image for round two and any spot
that is going to be fluorescent in both
of those images
is either a gene for a transcript of
gamma one
rp2 r12 or jspan3
and when you go through all ten images
that's how you can decode this multiplex
experiment and know which
of these spots correspond to a
transcript
of each of those genes and to decode
this
we use a software also provided by this
gen that
is called merlin and that's
what allowed me to generate images such
as the one that is
here where it's binary image and i'm
only putting a pixel
on if merlin decoded that at this
precise location
there was a transcript for jim's
teammate119 here
um a couple more details on that
we use a code book that is humming
weight 400 distance four
what that means is that any gene
will be three in four different channels
that's the humming weight four um and
hunting distance four
means that for inside that code book
any two genes will have at least four
bits that will be different
and doing that allows to correct errors
either in the
in the chemistry where some probes just
didn't anneal and made
a bit appear negative when it should be
positive for instance
or during decoding how do we do that for
instance
if uh we see a spot that has the
sequence shown here
uh this spot is worsened or appears
represented in five different channels
but this thing only has one difference
with the sequence we know
represents everyone so we are going to
say that this
spot is actually a transcript for gather
one
and because it is then different
from at least three differences from any
other gene in the code book
that also works for one to zero errors
we have a transcript that shows in these
three uh
different images here this one is also
only one bit different from the sequence
for the other one
so we can say that it is a transcript
for gap of one because it's also
different from at least three from any
other
of those genes okay so once we have
decoded the transcript
we still need to segment the cells and
count each of the genes within
each of those cells and here i chose to
use what we know of the biology of our
sample
we know we are only interested in
microglia which means that the cells
we're segmenting are isolated in that
brain
and that they express very specific
genes
so to segment those cells we use
the decoded images for transcripts of
the genes to mem119 and
fcrls that are specific to this
microglia
and i diluted dilated those uh
spots to make them bigger which
also makes dense areas
merge together into a bigger object and
then i was able to remove small objects
from this image so any isolated
spot here was removed and only the dense
areas
stayed and gave us the shape of yourself
and once that was done and we had to
count the transcript for every gene
in the library that we were measuring
inside those
cells there is one other
technical detail it's we also need
to segment the cells in v that is very
important here because we are interested
in
the level of expression of gaba
receptors in the microbial
and most likely the cells that are
neighboring those
microglia are neurons which express high
levels of this receptor
so what you're looking at here are the
counts for two
cells uh two microzia and
uh we're looking at the tens in each of
the these
that this micro this cell is found in
so on the left you can see that we have
very low
uh counts for microglia specific genes
in the zero to four or two three
and in these four five and six we see a
much higher term
of microbial specific genes so from that
we concluded that the microbial is
actually
in those layers and when we look at gaba
spots
you see that they are also within those
layers so cell one here is actually a
gaba resistor expressing microbial
whereas if we look at cell number two
here on the right
we see that the cell has is present in
layers 0
1 and 2 where we have high numbers of
spots for microbial specific genes
but if we look at gaba spots we see that
we don't see anything
in layers 0 1 2 3 4
but there are higher levels of gala
receptor transcripts
in the last layer and that most likely
indicates that
this last layer is actually part of a
neural and we don't want to segment this
but
in that layer with the microglia to do
that
we decided to use a threshold on the
number of spots for my previous
speed genes which means that i only
counted
the transcripts for all of those genes
in each of the disease if we found more
than five
microglia specific gene in the z we're
looking at
um finally i mentioned that we also
included some fish
genes in there how do we analyze those
this proves to be much more difficult uh
we have two options
either counts but for those uh
transcripts or
integrate the signal just on the surface
of the cell
so first we tried this and the output of
this analysis
actually did not match what we knew of
the biology of those genes
so we restarted and counted the spots in
cells instead so as you can see on this
example image here
even with the sm fish probe design we
can still see
a lot of spots that you can actually
count in both cells
and that actually matched much better
the the biology
we know of the sample but in those genes
that we were measuring
with sm fish we also had mitochondrial
genes
and obviously those are very clustered
in a very small
space and it's not possible here to
count isolated
transfers so we just uh
haven't done those ends and did analyze
further
now emilia is going to tell you how she
makes sense
of all of this data
right yes so the next thing we did was
to uh cluster uh these microglia
from the murphys profiling and actually
the clusters were
not too different from what we had found
with the single cell are in sequence and
in particular if you focus on this
cluster 4 and cluster 4 gg here um
you might recognize this uh gene i
showed you earlier with the single cell
around e6 again cluster 4 and 4g where
we're microclear that we're expressing
higher levels of homeostatic microbial
core genes and also
higher levels of pruning genes for
example this is
a well-known gene involved improving and
you can see that expression is higher in
both cluster 4 and 4g
but an important difference is that what
does gg mean
as they were uh microglially expressing
gaba b receptors and this was important
because besides the
expression of gaba b receptor we could
also identify additional genes that
represent a signature of this microglia
actually across different clusters it's
like this
these cell addition molecules of of the
testospinal family that were
particularly enriched in gaba-effective
microbial
we also had fascinating information so
we could see
that gabriel receptives microglia were
anatomically interspersed with uh
microglia that did not express kebab
receptors
and we also found that uh these
gabarescent microbes really uniformly
distributed across cortical layers in
the cerebral cortex
but then we could finally go back to our
initial question
about down regulated genes and sure
enough the same genes that we had
seen were down regulated with a single
cell or an asic
but also down regulated in the knockout
microglia again
pruning genes or genes involved in
chemotaxis or
phagocytosis but now we have an
additional information and what we found
was that these genes were
selectively down regulated in cluster 4
gg
so in gaba recessive microglia from
cluster 4 and not
in cluster 4 uh the
negative cells and not in other gabares
atomically and so what this really shows
is that the transcriptional changes that
we have observed in gaba binocular mice
indeed
are uh restricted to gaba receptive
microglia
or phelotonials and
and then the the last question that we
had uh
with what happens uh if you disrupt the
interaction between microgrid and
inimitate synapses at the behavioral
level
and uh to answer this question we used
music or motion sequencing that was
developed by
the data lab at harper medical school
and and mostly it really allows
unsupervised analysis of mouse behavior
and is based on the idea that behavior
is composed of specific
um motifs called syllables in music like
a specific type of run
or or a rare and they all come together
following a specific structure to
produce continuous behavior
and so when we looked at the usage of
syllables in uh controlling gaba b
knockout mice we found that the
knockouts down regulate
syllables um associated with different
types of
running or grooming and down regulate
syllables associated with pausing
behavior we also found that
there will be knockout mice had an
increased locomotor
activity suggesting overall
hyperactivity
and finally when we looked at these
state maps where the nodes
are the different syllables and the
edges are the transitions between them
we found that the uh knockout mice down
regulate the majority of the transitions
between syllables and so essentially
they
mainly oscillate within this repetitive
running and and grooming
uh so against order uh confirming the
hyperactivity and repetitive uh behavior
so to summarize what we show you um we
have seen that uh during development
gaba binds to gabap receptors on gabor
receptive
microbial and they they activate a
financial remodeling program increasing
utilities also
vision and phagocytosis and as a result
of that the cells
conduct more and more inhibitory
synapses over development
and and that's why if you remove all
microbial like in the depletion
uh you'll have an increase in both
excitatory and inhibitory
synapses but if you only remove gaba-b
receptors from microglia
you will selectively increase uh
inhibitory synapses
and we've also seen that these defects
will persist throughout the life of the
animal and will ultimately impact
behavior
and so finally i wanted to uh thank of
course a lot of people who worked on
this project uh first
of course michelle and a lot of uh
collaborators in the official lab
uh also our external collaborators beth
stevens and
uh more recently like karen and samid
were paid collaborators for the
murphys experiments uh bob data and this
postdoc is for the
music behavioral experiments and in
general all the kind people who shared
uh mice and
reagents with us and thank you and we're
happy to
take questions
thank you dr favouzi excuse me dr
favuzzi
and dr banan for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first
question is how many z planes
do you collect and what is the thickness
of the tissue used
hey thank you for the question um we
collect seven
z planes uh the tissue is 10 micron
thick
and so we collect the plane starting
from the level of the glass
and those planes are spaced by 1.5
micrometer
when occasionally a spot shows the same
identity
into consecutive z planes those spots
are filtered
during analysis to count the transcripts
only once
great thank you so much dr van on now
moving on to
our next question how many genes
did you probe with uh did you probe four
with the murfish
cycle i can go uh we probe 23 genes
um just because we had a specific
list from the uh single cell renaissance
but we could have definitely added more
thank you dr susie for that answer now
our next question um
let's go to okay here's one for you
this audience member says great
presentation could you please
explain how to analyze uh the gaba rb2
iso forms and i realized we have
four different iso forms of gabby arts
b2
and maybe i can start you know if george
won't plug something i mean that is a
good question we didn't
there's equal but we didn't
differentiate uh
among the different rising forms and our
gamma b probes were being designed for a
region that is common
uh for life forms but perhaps george
maybe can comment on the strategies that
can be implemented to design isoform
specific groups
yeah so i can elaborate a little bit on
the capacity
of murfish to detect isoforms
so so currently if there's enough
sequence difference between the two
splice variants that you want to
detect then we can design murfish probes
uh specifically
targeting that that different sequence
if the
difference in sequence is very small
then it becomes more challenging for us
to
identify isoforms but if that is
something that we're working
to improve so that we can even identify
splice variants with
very small sequence differences
thank you both for that answer and our
next question
in the brain tissue it is hard to
separate the neurals and astrocytes
because these cells have long axon and
dendrites so you mentioned that you can
use this technique for single cell
analysis
how could you recognize the single cell
from those complicated cells
in the case of microglia i was able to
segment more or less the shape of the
cell using the transcript
as i explained but in general when we
look at all those cell types that
together in the same sample
we're segmenting the cell body and we're
actually not looking at
what what is happening in the axons or
dendrites
thank you dr bernan for that answer um
our next question can you explain the
sample preparation
set for murfish
um yes so um well the first step is to
slice tissue and put it on the coverslip
by the way this is also doable with uh
cells from a cell line that you can just
play it on the coverslip
then essentially it's a very basic
cell fixation software mobilization and
then you incubate
with a library of encoding probes so
those are the
non-person probes that
i'm showing here on this schematic
and then to improve the noise to signal
ratio signal to noise ratio we clear the
tissue
so one thing that i'm not showing here
is that on top of those probes there is
a polyt capture probe that will
cross-link
the rna to a hydrogel in which we're
embedding the tissue
which then allows us to remove proteins
and lipids to make the images cleaner
and once all that is done the coverslip
is
uh interrelated in a microfluidic
chamber
and the fluorescent probes are floating
one
three at a time and then uh during
the imaging once three probes are
from one imaging round are imaged we
cleave and remove the three or four
that is shown here
okay that answers the question great
thank you so much
our next question did you see any effect
at
specific inhibitory synapses after
deleting gaba b receptors from
microglia
yeah and i'm seeing the rest of the
question about ssds and acid i think
that that is
an excellent question we did look at
different subtypes and the
the the whole scenario is particularly
interesting because
the effect is not specific for pv
synapses we do see a similar effect on
sst synapses as well but um
for instance uh the question ends with
uh the layer specificity indeed we do
see
this effect in layer four it looks like
in upper layers layer two three uh
it's less clear so there seems to be
some layer specificity
and when the part about the subtypes for
example vip synapses
uh do not seem to be affected so there's
heterogeneity for sure in the way these
the difference that inhibitory synapses
are affected by
microbial
thank you dr favuzi we still have time
for a couple more questions but i do
want to remind our audience
any questions that we are unable to get
to today will be answered by our
speakers
via the email address that you provided
at the time of registration
our next question is microglia pruning
of pv inputs specific to
pure medial cell targets or also seen at
pv inputs onto other inhibitory cells
that is another very good question um
it is specific for the inputs onto
pyramidal cells we didn't see any fat on
pvp synapses which is
particularly interesting because it
suggests that there is also something at
the level of this synapse that is
attracting microglia so
something that we definitely want to
follow up in the future yeah
great question thank you for that
it looks like we've got time for a
couple more questions so how many rounds
of reporter readout probe cycles
do you do for merfish
one of one of the most standard
setups in terms of the simplest code
book we can use
has 18 bits which we imagine six
imaging round with three bits per round
that allows us to target 140 barcodes
which we use to identify 130 genes and
10
blanks that are used for quality checks
so um yes 18
bits so that that is 18 different
fluorescent probes
thank you so much dr banan our next
question
is gather the receptor expression in
microglia transient only during the
development
um so this is complex because the b
receptors in microglia have two
different functions and it was shown
previously by the
kathmandu lab that uh gabba bircetter
has also important for the
anti-inflammatory role of gaba and so
the expression itself is not transient
because
in the adult you also have this
additional function also during
development so we also see some uh
evidence of that in our um sequencing
uh data and so uh definitely uh there's
changes uh during development in terms
of increasing expression that happens at
early postnatal stages and then it goes
up
uh but then it stays on uh probably
because of this additional function
thank you so much and it looks like
we've got time for one more
question so let's find our next question
here
how long does the gene have to be
successful for the murfish probe design
yeah so maybe i can elaborate a little
bit on the
murphish probe design so for merfish
just to make sure that we
maintain this very high detection
efficiency that we see with
single molecule fish we do try to tile
multiple probes
to each transcript so that in case one
of the probes doesn't bind we still have
a large fraction of the remaining probes
and we get a bright enough signal
from that transcript so we typically aim
for at least 30 target regions
so and then that with the length
considering the length of the target
region
that that brings the minimum length of
the gene to around
700 to 1000 nucleotides
so we are able to design probes for
shorter genes but it's just at the risk
of having
a lower detection efficiency for that
gene
thank you george for that answer i'm so
glad that you could join us for the q a
as well
we want to thank all of our speakers
today dr banan dr fufuzi and george
emanuel from bizgen
for their important research we would
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and they're submitting
all of their
amazing questions any questions again
that we didn't have time for
will be answered by our speakers via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
this webinar will be on demand labrets
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
bye bye everyone